après l'épidémie d'ebola qui a frappé
plusieurs pays africains en 2014 et qui
maintenant presque complètement
circonscrite c'est le spectre de
nouveaux conflits ethniques qui se
profile sur le continent plus
précisément au burundi si le pays est
plongé dans la violence depuis l'annoncé
au printemps dernier par le président
sortant pierre nkurunziza de briguer un
troisième mandat ce qui est contraire à
la constitution du pays
malgré une tentative de coup d'état et
des manifestations quotidiennes
pierre nkurunziza a tout de même été
réélu en juillet les assassinats ciblés
les violences entre une tour s'ils se
sont multipliés au point où l'onu a
lancé un cri d'alarmé des centaines de
morts des dizaines de milliers de
déplacés en quelques mois seulement deux
pays risquent de replonger dans une
guerre civile comme celle que le burundi
a connu entre 93 et 2006 et qui a fait
300 mille morts transition politique
difficile aussi au burkina faso après le
départ de l'ex président blaise compaore
qui est chassé par la rue il ya un peu
plus d'un an après 27 années au pouvoir
après un coup d'état militaire et un
putsch raté c'est finalement un ancien
ministre de compaoré roch kaboré qui est
élu à la tête du pays mais sans la
majorité absolue il va devoir travailler
très fort pour voir se réaliser ses
priorités quand par exemple la réforme
de l'armée dans le pays qui a connu une
bonne demi douzaine de coups d'état
militaires pour son histoire